from Love on screen
[Music]
to love IRL let's have a surprise hassie
Harrison and Ryan Bingham just confirmed
their real-life romance here we are now
the actors who play a couple on the
Paramount Network hit Yellowstone shared
this fiery snap on Instagram Wednesday
revealing their off-screen romance with
fans I love him Ryan captioned the post
quote more than a spark I would agree
with that yeah there's a lot there's a
lot happening for sure and hassie she
slid into the comments writing I love
you cowboy
where'd you come from
nowhere Ryan plays Walker on the series
a musician and former convict who is
recruited as a ranch hand he became a
series regular in season four
supposed to be dead
meanwhile hassie plays barrel racer and
ranch hand Laramie she joined the show
in season three are you too old to dance
ain't a damn thing I'm too old to do
and their love seems to have the
approval of some of their castmates Bob
Kirkland who plays Sheriff Ramsay
commented with three emojis heart eyes a
heart and a star while Jen Landon who
plays Teeter gave the post four heart
eye emojis yeah it's amazing it's hard
to wrap my brain around it Jeremy
Richardson who plays A Bar M cowboy in
season five commented as well writing
let's go happy for you too of course the
post comes amid questions about their
co-star Kevin Costner's future on the
series that's something you can't always
predict earlier this year it was
reported that the show might come to an
end sooner than expected amid a deadline
report alleging disagreements over
Kevin's filming schedule at the time a
spokes person for Paramount Network told
ET that the network had no news to
report adding that Kevin is a big part
of Yellowstone and they hope that's the
case for a long time to come and Kevin
his attorney echoed all that telling E.T
in a statement as everyone who knows
anything about Kevin is well aware he is
incredibly passionate about the show and
has always gone way above and beyond to
ensure its success Yellowstone is really
in limbo right now until they can figure
out whether Costner is coming back or
more likely whether he's going to be
written out of the show Once that
determination is made they can finish
writing the second half of this season
shoot it and it will likely air in the
fall earlier this month Keith Cox
president of development and production
at Paramount Network addressed rumors of
tension behind the scenes explaining
during a Paley Fest panel that he is
very confident Kevin will continue on
the show
[Music]
thank you